hey guys it feels like yesterday when i
was still in school
and since then so many things happened
over all these years
now i got two big youtube channels i
travel to over 20 different countries
and a lot of other things happened to me
good things
and bad things i lost family members as
well
but you know through it all i learned
valuable lessons mostly from all the bad
decisions i made from my mistakes
so in this video i want to share 10
mistakes that
every teenage guy needs to avoid
i'm doing this video because a lot of
guys these days don't have good role
models to look up to
you might not have anyone that points
you in the right direction
and i don't want you to make the same
mistakes as me
and so many other people out there in
the world so let's get to the video
[Music]
i've made mistakes but mistakes make you
strong
this is very quick if your first time
here on my channel welcome to dln model
lifestyle
i'm daniel and please consider
subscribing and also clicking that
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next
videos now guys most of you are still
very young you got your whole life in
front of you
and you're gonna have to make a lot of
decisions some
not so important but some will change
your life
and so i hope that i can help you with
some of the
decisions that you have to make and so
let's start with the first mistake
that you need to avoid
[Applause]
don't try to have many friends just try
to have a few good ones you know i'm
still friends with
my best friend from high school we're
still together and let me tell you
there's nothing that beats a good friend
that will stick by you through thick and
thin a good friend is something
that money cannot buy loyalty
trust respect honesty
and understanding these are the top
qualities that you need
to have in a good friend now some guys
say well i've got a lot of friends
but then when any kind of hardship
struck you
suddenly those friends nowhere to be
seen
when you think about it why are your
friends your friends are they your
friends
because they really care for you and
they like you or
is it all about what you can do for them
now while you grow older you will face
many challenges that this life will
throw at you
and that's when you will need good
friends that will stick by you
and family of course which takes us to
the next point
never put money before family the older
you get
the more you realize this and here's the
thing
your family won't always be here i lost
two brothers my dad also died recently
so don't take your family for granted
yes it's not always easy your family is
not perfect
they make mistakes and they will make a
lot more but so will you
so forgive them love them and appreciate
them
i won't see my brothers again in this
life
nor my father i lost them
but i did not lose all those wonderful
memories
so my advice to you is make more
memories
instead of money and do it right now
while you have time
[Music]
never choose money over passion
it's a lot of kids these days i feel so
sorry for them because their parents
keep on telling them things like you
have to be a doctor or you have to be a
lawyer
to just have enough money
but don't do it if it's not your passion
if it's your passion
and you think you will like it then of
course it's fine be a doctor
help people be a lawyer but don't do it
if you're not going to like it if it's
not your passion
let me give you an example here um
america it's a great first world country
right
right and even in america the conference
board reports that
53 of all americans are unhappy
at work that's so sad imagine that you
wake up every morning
you have to go to a job that you don't
like
you spend more time at your job than you
do at home
that's awful so this is very very
important so please
listen up find a job that you can live
out your passion because money will not
make you
happy by doing something that you love
that you have a passion for
that will make you happy and then if you
get money for it
that's even better so if you love
playing games you can become a game
developer
and then if you always like helping
people with their relationships
you can become a psychologist this world
is
huge so go out there look at all the
options
and choose the right one
don't believe everyone there's a lot of
innocent people there that just easily
trust people trust is earned
this world is not what it seems and it
will take some life experience to really
understand
what i'm telling you today be very very
careful with what you led
into your mind those cool tv series and
movies
that you keep on watching that's not
reality
and you don't need to be like them you
need to know that most celebrities out
there are not good role models
most of them are used by the media to
influence how you
think and feel about everything
now you need to know something there are
a very powerful group of elites
behind very big organizations and they
pull the strings
of news reporters celebrities and even
politicians
so before you just go and trust anything
you hear
ask yourself wait a minute is this
really true
or is there more to the story because
there usually
is more to the story one of the biggest
lessons that i learned is never to jump
to conclusions to make assumptions and
to always
think that i am right because
there's always more to the story
[Music]
never choose a shortcut over what is
right
you might think well it's going to be
easier and
no one is going to see you let me just
cheat a little here
but it will come back and bite you in
the ass
don't be lazy do what is required
the right way because then you'll do it
effectively and you'll learn
how to do it well whatever you do
always give your best and then you can
stand back
and say man i did all of this myself i
gave my all
and you can be proud about that now with
that said of course
you can find smarter ways of doing
things
but if it's unethical or wrong don't do
it
if it is right if it saves you time if
it is smarter then it's fine
but always remember be a man of honor a
good character
have integrity because that is what the
world
needs right now
don't be scared to speak your mind but
always remember to do it with a humble
attitude
and then do it with love and compassion
for example if you meet people from
other religions or different world views
then hear them out hear what they have
to say don't feel defensive
and listen and then you can also tell
them what you
believe why should you speak with love
and compassion
because if you don't you will come off
as aggressive or arrogant and nobody
wants to listen to aggressive and
arrogant people
in fact most people don't so you think
you're explaining to this guy that he
has to believe you
this is number one this is number two
this is number three
and what's wrong with you you're wrong
you think he's listening
but he's not even listening to you
because he switched off
because of the way that you talk to him
so remember it's not just what you say
but it's how you say it
[Music]
listen to good role models and please
don't tell me
your good role models are rappers who
just use swear words and
they just curse and talk about all the
bad stuff in the world all the time
or some celebrity who's just in and out
of rehab all the time
if you don't have good role models then
get people
who you can really look up to strong
role models that are
open they speak the truth they have
integrity they have a good
character and they are full of wisdom
one of my big role models is ravi
zechariah unfortunately he passed away
recently
but other role models are martin luther
and jesus and also
my dad who passed away recently listen
to wise people
don't always think that you know
everything because that just shows that
you still have much to learn walk with
the wise to become
wise and remember the more you talk
the more you just repeat things that you
already know so you don't grow
but the more you listen the more you
learn
and the more you grow
don't make hasty decisions especially if
it's a big decision
you know i used to do that a lot when i
was younger and i made so many stupid
mistakes i just
jumped into something without even
thinking about
the consequences and i've hurt a lot of
people
and i can't go back in time to change it
to redo it
all i could do is just go and say i'm
sorry to apologize
try to make it right so before you just
jump in and do
something think what will the
consequences be
how will it influence me and those
around me what are my other options
is it really the right time and is it
the right thing
to do
don't just focus on the bad again media
mostly just shows us bad things because
they know
psychologically humans tend to focus on
bad things more so they get more views
and i used to focus a lot on bad things
and things that happened in the world
and i wanted to
change the world change people for the
better but i became
very negative because i felt i couldn't
change everything
but then one day i realized something i
don't need to change everybody
i just need to change some people i can
only do
what i can do i might not be able to
change the whole world
but i can change a few people and make a
difference in their lives
so i decided to look at life in a
balanced way
it's bad of course but it's a lot of
good and so i started to focus more on
the good
so while you're growing older choose for
yourself
to enjoy life and yes it is a decision
that you can make
enjoy nature enjoy sport
and enjoy good food
[Music]
there's so much good out there in the
world we tend to just focus on a
negative but it's
so much good so start today and look out
for all the good in your life
don't waste your time you're still young
you might think hey i've still got 70
years to go
oh no not everyone will live to be 80
years old
my two brothers they died in their early
twenties
so don't waste the time that you've been
given by god
use it for good you can always get more
money
but you can never get more time so
please
don't waste your time by being lazy
and ignoring opportunities use the time
that you've been given
with your talents and make the most of
it
and remember most of all use this life
to prepare
for the one that comes next
think about it for a little while let it
sink in and i'll see you
in the next video cheers guys